يا عم والله ما تقلق اصبر شويه هو بشتغل
مصلحتك ارفع ايدك على رجلك ارفع ايدك ارفع
ايدك
خ يا عم سيبك من
العينيه يلا يا عم معلش معلش تحمل يا عم
تحمل
معلش كريم يلا يا كريم بسم الله يا كريم
بسم الله بسم
الله خلصنا يا كريم خلصنا شاطر شاطر شاطر
ما شاء الله عنك ما شاء الله عنك تحركش
رجلك تحركش ولا حاجه تتحركش تتحركش يا
كريم شاطر شاطر شاطر ما شاء الله عنه ما
شاء الله عنه اخوان ارجعوا
شويه خلصنا ما شاء الله حط اكسجين يلا يا
شباب خلصنا جدع شباب افتحوا لنا الطريق بس
للدفاع المدني ما حد ما ماشي خل بس الله
يكر خليك يا با با اصبر اص يلا يا كريم
طيب صبوحه وين ماما ماما وين كانت
وقع انت جنبهم كاين
لا جنبهم في نفس الغرفه هات مين معض يعني
ام جنبك وين الشب اللي معه الاغراض شاطر
يا بابا الكريب باندان بابا الرباط الرباط
الضاغط يا حبيبي حبيبي يا بابا انت بطل يا
بابا طيب يا بابا والله اللي اجيب لك
اياها يابا انت وصبو حه
لاش خلص احنا كويسين يا بابا صح انت قلت
انا قوي اسمع الكلام كريم جدع صح يا بابا
ايشك تجيبله بجيب
[موسيقى]
له
كانت ناموا على جنبه يمن يلا بسم الله يلا
يا كريم يلا يا
كريم يلا
ترك
بالراحه روق على الله يلا روح يلا امنهم
الطريق ما حد يتحرك عنده ما تعود
عليه سيدنا محمد عين
ايش ماشي
ماي